it's a distinctly different tone from
the Chinese regretful almost contrite
about its balloon over American airspace
China is a responsible country that
abides by International laws said the
foreign Ministry spokesperson it has no
intention of violating the airspace of
any sovereign country but Chinese
intentions are very much in question for
a balloon the U.S says didn't arrive by
accident
I am trying to verify the situation she
said and speculation and hype will not
help resolve the issue
just weeks ago a Chinese fighter jet
flew within meters of a U.S aircraft
over the South China Sea no such
Contrition the timing of the balloon may
have been a blunder says one expert but
under Xi Jinping China is willing to
challenge America's power and Global
reach the launching of what may well be
a military will learn
shows that increasing capacity of China
across across the board to challenge the
West to challenge the United States
showing the path for a balloon from
China One analyst using American
government data plotted the possible
though unverified route over Canada and
remarkably right over Montana the home
of nuclear missile silos and carrying on
over the continental United States
balloons were used in war for more than
a hundred years by combatants to gather
intelligence on the enemy but in the
space age for the last 60 years balloons
gave way to spy satellites but this
suggests a comeback for balloons and a
new technological advantage for China
given the fact that there are Advanced
anti-satellite capabilities having
another option in terms of a
balloon-based surveillance kit it makes
a certain amount of sense
the U.S angered the Chinese with their
own Navy fighter jets flying over the
South China Sea just last week an
incursion by a Chinese balloon in
American airspace only increases tension
and diminishes Trust on both sides I
think that tensions will be increased it
will be harder for the Biden
Administration to make concessions to
China to try and and Tamp down the
rising tensions the balloon is
geopolitically provocative and China had
to know it would be but for now Beijing
must wait the balloon is in American
airspace and the next move will come
from Washington Eric Sorensen Global
News